dos meses después de las elecciones de
noviembre los votantes de georgia
todavía tienen un asunto pendiente
otorgar los dos escaños que definirán la
mayoría en el recién posesionado senado
de eeuu
los más recientes comicios no sólo
pusieron nuevo inquilino en la casa
blanca también refrescaron un tercio del
senado pero la elección está incompleta
georgia se vio abocado a una segunda
vuelta ya que ninguno de los candidatos
alcanzó el 50 por ciento de los votos
hasta el momento el partido republicano
tiene asegurados de 50 asientos y los
demócratas 48 los dos pendientes
dependen de los comicios locales que
tendrán lugar este martes del 5 de enero
los candidatos republicanos dave y de
perdiz y kelly löffler se enfrentan en
respectivamente al documentalista john
joseph y al reverendo raphael warnock
pastor de una iglesia en atlanta
tras cuatro años de odio racismo
división y fanatismo georgia dejara
claro su mensaje sobre amor decencia
compasión y unidad porque eso es lo que
georgia representa las mayores
transporte
y vamos a seguir luchando por el
presidente de trump
[Aplausos]
y él puso a eeuu primero creyó en el
país desde el primer momento los
demócratas no creen en eso lo que está
en juego no sólo son dos sillas
legislativas es el destino de la agenda
liberal que quiere impulsar el
presidente electo joe biden la cámara
alta- también es vital para ratificar
los nombramientos son los principales
puestos del ejecutivo empezando por
todos los secretarios de estado
basta con que gane un solo republicano
para que su colectividad de extienda su
hegemonía por dos años pero si los que
seducen al electorado son sus rivales el
escenario será más llamativo un senado
de 50/50 en el que la vicepresidenta de
elekta kamala harris se encargaría de
los desempates una vez presten juramento
el próximo 20 de enero